foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists well I would say
TK's in the studio but he's not here
today he has a children's cold and we
didn't want everyone to get sick
speaking of everyone we got malabama
here today hi everybody we got the rest
of our team as well coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
joined by Wendy Smith author of this
book right here both and thinking a book
that discusses embracing creative
tensions to solve your toughest problems
today we're talking to a listener about
inner conflict and the tension that is
interwoven with that inner conflict when
you're making big life-altering
decisions we also have an outstanding
lightning round listener tip and added
value segment for you you can check out
the full two hour maximal edition of
episode 364 where we answer four times
the questions with Wendy and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com the minimalists
your support keeps our podcast and
YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all
advertisements suck all right let's get
to our first question
hey there Brian from Grand Rapids
Minnesota and I am a thankful VIP Patron
I'm looking for some guidance or
potential strategies for helping shorten
a cycle of inner conflict that I see
repeat my life over and over but until
now I've not been able to step back and
recognize I'll use the latest example
for me because it condensed what another
examples may take days weeks or months
to transpire into less than an hour from
start to finish last week I visited a
local restaurant I had never visited
before to pick up some takeout food and
within the span of two minutes of trying
to navigate this place I walked in on
both the kitchen staff and the woman's
bathroom it was a quick double hit of
embarrassment that really frustrated me
at a deep level herein lies my inner
conflict cycle
whenever I do something wrong or
embarrassing I immediately Spike into
some disgust and self-loathing like what
the hell dude in a quick Litany of other
similar comments in my mind then I
transitioned from those into a kiddie
pool of Shame where I sit there and tell
I'm pretty convinced of those untrue and
hurtful comments then finally whether a
quick cycle of inner conflict like this
one or more serious ones that could take
me weeks or months or even years to work
through I make it to perspective and
wisdom so in perspective and wisdom I
stepped out of the kiddie pool and spoke
the truth that you're not an idiot you
had never been there before the doors
were not well marked and you will
definitely know your way around next
time all is well essentially I crave the
quick succession I had in this example
from event to laughing it off and moving
on and can't help but wonder if I could
get better at this life hacking so that
this inner conflict in more serious
areas of my life could be overcome is
there anything I can do to Short Circuit
this cycle and get to perspective and
wisdom so that I can see things as they
actually are more quickly
now Wendy obviously there's conflict
here but it's certainly
inner conflict and exclusively inner
conflict although I think at some level
you could say every ounce of conflict is
ultimately inner conflict right because
how he's reacting he's reacting in a way
that is bringing him shame or disgust or
he's feeling inadequate in the moment he
feels stupid ah what an idiot and
there's a certain narrative we all tell
ourselves right and sometimes it's oh
I'm such an idiot or other times it's
I'm awesome right and neither one of
those are necessarily earned it's just a
story We Tell ourselves now in the book
you talk about tension and dilemma this
is a dilemma of his for sure that's
causing some sort of tension in his life
so how do we unpack the wisdom that you
have in the book with respect to dilemma
and help Brian better understand where
he goes from here
I love the question Brian great example
paradoxically
the way to let go of our difficult
emotions is we have to start by
accepting them you guys have talked
about this on the show before that if we
feel that immediate sense of
embarrassment it can lead to these
long-standing Vicious Cycles we feel
embarrassed we feel shame that we feel
embarrassed we want to let go of that
difficult emotion so we feel guilt that
we can't let go of it and then these
difficult emotions have a strong hold on
us
the alternative is that instead of
trying to push them aside move on
quickly we can move on by starting to
accept them so in the book we talk about
finding comfort in the discomfort and
what we mean by that is not ignore the
discomfort hide it under the rug pretend
it doesn't exist it's acknowledging
recognizing accepting the discomfort
and here I am a big fan of Tara Brock
she is a Buddhist psychologist and she
talks about radical acceptance and what
she would say and Brian here's the short
circuit is to start with saying yes to
all those emotions yes I feel
embarrassed yes I feel shame yes I feel
a little guilty that I can't let yes and
it's through that yes that we can
allow their stronghold to loosen on us
and move forward yeah I love the uh
learning how to live with it I had I was
talking to someone
years ago
um kind of uh I have had like addiction
problems in the past and he was someone
who uh was sober and I asked them I'm
like hey man I really want to let go of
this like how kind of let go of it and
he was like well that's that's the
problem he's like you're gonna have to
live with it there's no letting go and
you have to like dance with it on a
day-to-day basis and like learn how to
uh let yeah learn how to have those
impulses in your life and yeah I totally
agree it's interesting to me because
like
the person that I treat the worst it's
me right like I would never call Josh an
idiot I would never call him Alabama an
idiot but I look in the mirror all the
time and I'm like oh you idiot I can't
believe you did that thing and I had to
catch myself when I'm when I'm talking
to myself that way because I know it's
not helping the situation and uh makes
me think about in your book how y'all
talk about these uh like groups of folks
I'm paraphrasing so correct me where I'm
like really off base here Wendy but uh
you base you know basically one group
was told hey you're you're a standout
group right and uh you have potential to
really like have these crazy big growth
spurts and then the other group wasn't
told anything and there was nothing that
um uh that that led to you telling the
group this except for this was the group
that you told it to that was it and um
if I remember correctly like there was a
pretty high percentage of people in that
group that just had that one little you
know one little seed planted that
actually were doing better in certain
areas just because they were given that
that uh that encouragement of hey you're
someone who stands out and when I was
reading that I'm like oh this is why
mantras are so important right yeah our
mindsets matter it's not and it's our
hearts and our mind they have to work
together how we frame something matters
so that's important
um I'm a huge fan of the Buddhist idea
of not shooting the second Arrow have
you heard of this so the Buddhist idea
is that we feel pain we don't have to
engage in the suffering along with the
pain so the first Arrow hits us it's
painful but then we feel so anxious
about standing in the way and we make
ourselves feel bad about the fact that
we feel pain that we expand exacerbate
the suffering so how can we acknowledge
the pain acknowledge the addiction
acknowledge the embarrassment
acknowledge the shame acknowledge that
we walked into the women's bathroom
instead of the men's bathroom honor it
but not let it expand and expand
eventually grow so that it defines how
we go forward yeah I think there's
something here about intentions as well
intentions aren't everything but they
certainly matter here like if he
intended to sneak into the women's
bathroom that's different from oh I made
a mistake of course a mistake ceases to
be a mistake once you've learned a
lesson from it and by the way if you've
done it once you're probably not going
to make that same mistake over and over
and over unless you just choose to
forget the lesson that you've learned
right I'm also thinking about what
Brian's saying here about the
embarrassment yes it's okay to get
embarrassed to acknowledge that
emotionally to pick it up right but then
when we cling I think this is what
you're saying with the second arrow
thing when we cling to that
embarrassment it's much more difficult
to let it go how do you let go of
something you simply cease the clinging
right so you can see the embarrassment
oh I picked this up huh I guess I can
set it down now as well and as you set
it down more and more and that's all
that Brian's really looking to do I
don't have a how-to for you but the
deeper understanding here is everything
that you've picked up you can put down
and the sooner you see it for what it is
you know if I think I'm picking up my
luggage and I look down there's a snake
in my hand you don't need to tell me the
seven steps to Let It Go
[Laughter]
I'm merely going to stop clinging
immediately I'm going to get it away
from me as quickly as possible the same
thing is true with any of these other
so-called negative emotions they're not
really bad emotions they're they're
merely data telling you something about
the decisions or the actions that you've
made and informing you how to make
different decisions or actions in the
future we have a we have several
colleagues working on this idea of
emotional ambivalence meaning we have
these what we would seem as good and bad
emotions happening at the same time and
that's what leads us to actually be more
productive so we have these these
emotions that we see as negative
embarrassment shame and those from those
are what we learn we need those and yet
if we hold on to that too tightly and
not add in the we can learn we can
engage then we're stuck in this vicious
cycle but if we can say oh I learned I
shouldn't walk into that bathroom
because that's the wrong bathroom and I
felt shame or felt embarrassed that's
what led me to learn that well then we
can use them productively so how so our
colleague Naomi Rothman at Lehigh talks
about the value of emotional ambivalence
bringing these two types of emotions
together to allow us to productively and
creatively move forward Josh is very
good at emotional ambivalence
the nicest way anyone's ever called me
apathetic
I don't know but something that I use
for myself is when I find myself uh
being so negative I start to think about
like how would I talk to a five-year-old
or like how would I talk to the
five-year-old Ryan Nicodemus and like
that kind of helps me get a little bit
more compassion for myself
um yeah just one little technique yeah I
had a moment just just this past week uh
where I was starting into that downward
emotional spiral I was tired tired makes
me feel a little grumpy I got home the
dishes were in the sink dishes in the
sink make me feel grumpy then they make
me feel angry then I start to blame then
I start to wonder where my kids and
husband were to do the dishes and this
thing and it was about to spiral into
something really negative and I just
paused right I just pause it's yeah I'm
tired yes yes I'm grumpy yes this
grumpiness makes me feel angry yes I
don't need to act on that so it just it
diffuses that negative emotion gives us
that pause if you will so we don't need
to behave based on those negative
emotions that lead to even more shame
guilt anger frustration and that
downward spiral yeah we start to get
into this should thinking right uh these
dishes should have been done
um I shouldn't have to feel this way and
yeah acknowledging it and being like Oh
like there are no shuts like this is the
way it is it's that's a very ambivalent
approach it's not uh it's not good or
bad it's just an observation and uh yeah
I totally agree it's it's a great way to
kind of help diffuse things and calm it
down a little bit right the kids were
really happy that I did that too
our our friend Dan Harris who you all
listeners know from our first
documentary minimalism he just put out a
TED Talk and he talks about the downward
toilet spiral of emotions right but the
counter to that is after you pause
there's also an upward yes spiral and
joy begets Joy contentment begets
contentment contribution begets
contribution love yes begets love caring
begets caring and so it becomes
infectious your negative emotions
so-called negative emotions if you're
raging or angry yes other people are
going to feel that they're going to
sense that but if you're joyous and you
pause and you make room because Joy does
have room for grief it has room for
sadness it has room for discontent it
has room for confusion if we have that
pause then we can have that upward
spiral of beautiful emotions that are
contagious for the people around us yes
Brian I'd love to send you a copy of
both and thinking by Wendy Smith and uh
Marianne Lewis and uh we'll put a link
to the book in the show notes as well
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and your
comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round Wendy this is where we
and our guests we answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media you can find all
of those minimal maxims over it the
minimalists.com podcast right there in
the show notes but really you can wander
on a bit Professor Sean puts a minute on
the clock for each of us and allows us
to pontificate our our pithy answer a
little bit we have a question today from
Becky my mother-in-law and I have a
strained relationship but I know she is
important to my son and my husband how
do you manage a difficult relationship
with someone you can't cut out of your
life you can throw 60 seconds on the
clock for me Prof Sean you know TK was
supposed to be here today but he has the
great Siberian itch
[Laughter]
I don't know
it was Alan wattsism
so but he did give us a pithy answer I
wanted to use his I'm going to steal his
for a second then I'll give you mine you
can let something go without throwing it
away I would say the opposite is also
true you can throw something away and
you haven't let it go in your heart and
the same is true with a relationship or
an expectation or a demand of someone
else I need you to be this way it's
possible with our things to Let It Go
but still be holding on to a cling to it
or with our things they can add value to
our lives they can be nice I can have
them around me but I have let them go in
the sense that I don't need them to live
a fulfilled life here's one other thing
I'll say to you the closer you are to
someone the greater the chaos
I wish I had more on time to unpack that
one perfect that was right at a minute
that was like to the micro second boom
um all right Mahala give me 60 seconds
uh here's my here's my pithy answer uh
compassion can conceives connection or
you could say compassion creates
connection
um whatever version of alliteration you
like but here's the thing is you don't
have to agree with someone you don't
have to uh necessarily support someone
or help someone or uh radically accept
them to show them compassion you can
show compassion at any time and that I
feel like that is the default emotion or
the default action that will always
at least help a situation not escalate
so for me when I'm around family when
I'm around friends if things start to
escalate I start to get a little annoyed
I hold my context of how can I show
these people compassion in the moment
and that will always I think that's
always the right answer
Wendy before we throw some time on the
clock for you Becky's struggling here
because there's an either or thing and
uh it's making that room for the
compassion is is important understanding
the closer we get to someone there is
going to be some sort of chaos right I
think that's inevitable what do you have
to say to Becky and and her struggle
here
it's a version Ryan of what you said uh
and we don't need to agree judge we need
to understand and respect and I would
start with just listen there might be a
whole bunch of reasons that there's
tension with your mother-in-law I can
imagine exactly many of those and great
relationships are founded on trust
respect the way to get to that trust and
respect is to just listen to what we all
want in the world is people to listen to
us they don't agree with us but to
listen to honor us just listen I have a
colleague in uh Pennsylvania Sharon
Browning who talks about just listening
listening is an act of Justice how can
you start out by creating more honor
respect dignity in that relationship by
listening oh I love that and she did it
within a minute that's awesome nice yeah
it's almost like listening is an act of
compassion in a way too yes yeah
well let's check in real quick with our
patreon live stream every Tuesday at 10
A.M we check in with our video private
podcast subscribers and they ask us some
questions and comment and they interact
with each other as well you can find
that at patreon.com the minimalist from
Alabama what do you got for us I have a
question here from Kate she says I have
a paradox I know I want to leave the job
I have but I don't I'm conflicted
internally about what I want to do next
but it's been two years now any thoughts
Wendy is this a paradox of comfort in a
way because once upon a time I was
talking to Danny Unknown about this this
weekend Ryan and I when we were in the
corporate world it's not that I hated my
job I wanted to get out of here right
away it's like oh this is pretty
comfortable I'm pretty good at this I'm
pretty skilled at it I am competent by
the way I'm getting these little food
pellets of nutrition from the universe
they're telling me I'm special I'm
unique I'm I am who I am in fact when we
meet someone what do we say uh what do
you do and I had an impressive answer to
what do you do I'm the director of
operations for 150 retail stores and I
didn't really care about that but I
cared so much about what other people
thought of me I'm an Enneagram three yes
and so that that makes a lot of sense
when people I need to put on the masks
to impress other people I mean you still
have a great answer to that question
oh what do you do I tie my shoes really
quickly right yeah which I would have
been really impressed myself in your old
self I was still doing velcro
but Comfort was the problem my life was
sort of a six out of ten and were afraid
of losing that comfort and therefore not
ever experiencing the real discomfort
that encourages us to make the change
that may be more beneficial more
rewarding for us in a not too distant
future this is the rabbit hole this is
the Vicious Cycle that we get when we
emphasize one piece of something and
don't let ourselves see the alternative
so we've emphasized and it's exactly all
the reasons you just said we emphasize
our expertise we continue to rely on our
expertise we continue to rely on our
identities we continue it becomes
inertia and all of a sudden our
expertise the great things that it was
offering us become shackle us instead of
enable us and that's when we start
falling down that rabbit hole we get
stuck into until we can't get out and
until we get into these really tragic
situations or really difficult
situations that voice us out because we
have no alternative but to you know that
that's the only alternative and so
that's the Vicious Cycle of the rabbit
hole the question is how do we not go
down the rabbit hole in the first place
there's some great research Eric Dane of
competence traps our competencies our
expertise as individuals you know the if
everything is a hat if everything
everything if I have a hammer everything
is a nail we get stuck and we can't see
the other possibilities yeah yeah it's
uh
this question really resonates with me
because
you know Josh and I were both at that
point where we're kind of at a boiling
point we had to like get out
and I really wish I would have and I did
to an extent I mean I got laid off um
but about a year before I got laid off I
started simplifying and paying down debt
and really kind of preparing to leave my
job now nothing could have prepared me
for being laid off when I was but at
least I started doing something because
when I did get laid off I was like oh
okay like I was gonna leave anyway I
mean now I'm just kind of forced out of
it
um but you know I guess and I don't have
an answer to this but I do hate to see
when people are kind of in this
situation you know they said they've
been uh two years with this mindset and
if you let it go another two years it's
going to be 10 times worse the feeling's
going to be 10 times worse
um so yeah I mean it's maybe it's a
matter of like altering kind of the way
that you're perceiving this job but um I
don't again I don't have an answer to
this but like I I just I don't want to
see it get to a boiling point for the
person who asks this question here's
something else we find in the work that
we do and the workshops that we do and
when we is that when we invite people so
they're both and here is how do you take
advantage of all your experience all
your expertise all the things that
you've built up and try something new
and experiment and be creative how do
you deal with that what we find in the
workshops that we do is that it is so
much harder to find our own both ands
and so much easier to find other people
and so in our workshops we invite people
to think about their own tensions their
own dilemmas then think about something
else more creative somebody else's both
and they can totally easily do that and
then we invite them back to their own
but instead of inviting them back to
their own and having them come up with
their own Solutions we say pair and
share tell somebody else next to you and
have them be open to what they have to
say and the AHA here is getting out of
our own heads and whether that's a paid
professional therapist or a best friend
or an accountability partner or somebody
else who you trust to explore your both
and and who you're not going to reject
and defend against that's an opportunity
to help you think about new
possibilities yeah you know the one
thing that held me back from leaving the
job was money right like we have to pay
bills yeah and for me I was living
paycheck to paycheck in fact I was
living in a deficit each month like no
matter what my paycheck was like I was
spending more on credit cards than what
I was making and what uh what I did is I
changed those habits and then I saved up
about I got to about three months of
savings and then I got laid off and I'm
like oh no like I was hoping to get six
months so I could have six months to
kind of figure things out try new things
um but because I was forced into it I'm
like okay if I sell my car right now if
I move out of my house right now and
rent it out and if I if I go to this
smaller apartment
um and get get rid of my car payment I
can make that three months six months
yeah so um that's just one little
ingredient that I used and I hope that I
hope that resonates with you somehow but
I'm sure money is like one of the
biggest things holding back this person
from quitting and right I'll just say
quickly the money is partially the
reality of the money and it's also the
fear the emotions and navigating these
tensions we talk about four buckets of
things that have to happen all together
in a system and two of those are
changing our mindsets as we said earlier
our head but also noticing our emotions
The Head and the Heart they both have to
be aligned or we have to attend to both
of them it's a great Point ladies and
gentlemen Wendy Smith yes
thank you Wendy I want to encourage you
to check out the book it's called both
and thinking I'll hold it up if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast Ryan and I got a lot more to
talk about we're going to do a little
house tour I got this article about
retail therapy and how it's really
increasing lately post pandemic we'll
we'll talk about that we've got some
other simple living segments as well but
first i'm Alabama what do you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners
hey Josh and Ryan my name is Jenny and
I'm calling from Sheboygan Wisconsin
with two useful tips we have a local
service called waste not LLC and it's a
compost service what they do is they
give you a bucket that you can fill up
with compostable items and once a week
they come and pick it up right from your
doorstep and they compost it while
working with local farms our family
loves to collect compostable items our
kids are even involved with it too and
we've explained the process and how
composting helps our planet with our two
young kids so this is a great service
that they do they work for you for a
small cost and you actually get to
assist with local farms my second tip is
for baby care it's an organization that
is within our local food bank here in
Sheboygan and I know that there are
other organizations such as this and
other cities what they do is they
collect all baby items anything from
formula to clothes diapers any baby
related items and they give it to
families that are in need instead of
keeping clothes that no longer fit our
kids or diapers that they have grown out
of or just any other things related to
kids we have chosen to donate them and
we see it as helping other kids in our
community so rather than them collecting
dust on a shelf or in a container we see
them as an opportunity to help others in
need let's return to the public version
of the podcast real quick Ron I got a
great added value segment for you
something way out of left field before
we get to that real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist or
should I say four things going on in the
life of the minimals or maybe it's just
one thing it's tick tock we were talking
about this on the private podcast
earlier but we have four different ways
to simplify or maybe enhance amplify
your Tick Tock feed there's four
different accounts of course you could
follow the minimalists on Tick Tock
we're just at the minimalists you can
follow my writing class on Tick Tock how
to write better if you want different
writing tips and writing insights we
have how to love my wife's podcast so
you relationship insights and then if
you really want some beauty in your life
minimalist design minimalist
architecture minimalist well-being you
can follow our side project it's called
minimalism life and it's just at
minimalism on Tick Tock we'll put a link
to all of those in the show notes but if
you're looking if you're on Tick Tock
and you're looking to enhance your Tick
Tock feed you can follow the minimalists
you can follow how to write better you
can follow how to love and you can
follow at minimalism for our added value
segment this week Ryan I have a towel
nice
awesome this Tau adds value to my life
cool goodbye everybody
so here's the thing right I have had the
same beach towels
since we lived in Montana which I didn't
have to use very frequently in Montana
strangely
occasionally we'd go up to Flathead Lake
and I would need some sort of tap but
Ella hated our towels they were too thin
they were old they were falling apart
and she kept saying oh I want a
different towel and eventually I'm like
okay we we've had these towels forever
they're tattered they're falling apart
they're a decade old we need to do
something else with our towels like the
towels were older than Ella and so I
started researching trying to find a a
towel that works really well but B one
that didn't break the bank and I found
it it's called I don't know exclusivo I
I'll put a link to it in the show notes
Ryan you can check it out here I'll put
it up on the screen you can wrap
yourself in it Ryan it is very soft and
here's here's what I'll say I got this
off of Amazon I looked at the reviews
the reviews were awesome and it comes in
a bunch of different colors as well so
right now Jordan through his own Magic
on the screen he's going to put up it
comes in green and it comes in pink and
it comes in blue
he's a real wizard is that I'm allowed
to say wizard I think magic person
I believe that's the politically correct
term yes yes oh all of the Wizards will
be happy that you use that politically
correct term so I'm not encouraging you
to go get brand new towels if you don't
need them but if you were looking I
spent so much time researching these
towels the exclusivo and by the way this
is obviously not an ad it's a 100 cotton
super absorbent soft plush oversized 35
by 70 Cabana stripe beach towel this
totally sounds like a knife it does it's
great uh no so the use promo code
to be charged twice as much yeah
um
I will say one thing Melbourne that I
really appreciate about you is that
because you do have such uh you pay such
close attention to detail like if I need
to replace something like I have a
vacuum that you know Mariah and I have
had for nine years and uh it is falling
apart yes and I see that you have one
um that's different than the one that I
have so like I can be like oh how does
that work and like I know that you've
gone out of your way to like get
something of quality so with the beach
towels yeah that's a great
recommendation uh Mariah and I went out
and got um so we were at I could
probably talk about the as a private
podcast I know we're back on the public
one it doesn't matter we're at someone's
house that we were doing an interview a
podcast with in Portland Oregon and they
had these um context
contacts towels contacts cotton towels
and it was like I was drying my hands
I'm like oh my goodness like these are
the soft this is like the softest towel
I've ever felt in my life and then I
went to go look it up and they were like
300 something dollars a time but I'm
like oh I'm not spending 300 bucks on a
towel but I did find a substitute
um anyway long story short a good soft
towel is like a game changer and this
total game this is relatively
inexpensive I also say this you have to
watch wash it twice because there's a
lot of lint you have to get out of it
the first two Washings by the way Ryan
we got a bunch more surprise questions
on the private podcast this week like
what is the once a month rule what is
the most disappointing advertisement
that we have ever heard and man were we
disappointed how do I choose between
starting my dream career and starting a
family plus a million more questions for
Wendy and the minimalists and if I want
to hear all that Alabama tell them what
to do check out the minimalist private
podcast visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of Live
Events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com the minimalists if you have
a question or listener tip for our
podcast give us a call
[Music]
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
follow the minimalists on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalists and to get our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at theminimalist.com thank
you Alabama that is our show for today
on behalf of Ryan Nicodemus TK Coleman
Alabama podcast Sean Jordan no more
Professor Sean social just Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team I'm Joshua
Fields Milburn reminding you too love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it